[musique]
ce n'est pas pour ça qu'ils se sont battus
défendu notre Terre pour qu'aujourd'hui
pris le pouvoir
tu as donné ta première fidélité
au peuple ukrainien
et les dessins animés internationaux sont acceptés par moi
décision de mener des opérations militaires spéciales
opérations afin qu’il n’essaye pas d’interférer avec nous et
surtout pour créer des menaces pour notre
les pays que notre peuple devrait savoir
que la réponse de la Russie sera immédiate et
vous mènera à de telles conséquences avec
ce que vous n'avez jamais connu auparavant dans votre histoire
n'a pas
[musique]
L'Europe est envahie par la végétation, hélas, au contraire, remplis ta poitrine
La centrale nucléaire européenne elle-même à la fois
Cependant, hier soir, sur la rue adjacente
territoire de la centrale électrique de Kyiv
était un régime nationaliste
une tentative a été faite pour mettre en œuvre
provocation monstrueuse
[musique]
aujourd'hui plié et pour un moment d'insouciance
pour la décision du commandement du temple après tout
aujourd'hui 15 Bereznya à partir de 20:00 à Kiev pour
a droit au melon du commandant pour
défense en dispersant le démon mistu spécial
[musique]
les parenthèses les plus hautes radicales 100 ont donné l'ordre
afin de vivre la viscose santé
garnison
chantier de défense
[musique]
[applaudissements]
maintenant le nôtre
Je suis ce monsieur de la rébellion le plus précieux
[musique]
vous pouvez acheter les territoires de notre état
Elle ne peut certainement pas l'acheter
notre peuple est le peuple ukrainien
[musique]
à savoir, pour protéger notre patrie
souveraineté et territoire
intégrité Pour assurer la sécurité
notre peuple et le peuple libéré
territoires que je considère nécessaires
soutenir les propositions du ministère
défense et état-major
organisé en Fédération de Russie
mobilisation partielle
[musique]
je ne veux pas tuer des gens
rester
[musique]
les gens vivant à Lougansk Donetsk Kherson
Zaporojie devient nos citoyens
pour toujours
[musique]
Ukraine, une fois de plus, vous dites la vérité
Les élites occidentales ne cachent pas leurs objectifs
infliger à la Russie comme on le dit
discours direct
défaite stratégique de la Russie Qu'est-ce que c'est
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie pour nous ?
finissez-nous une fois pour toutes
ils ont l'intention de traduire les langues locales
phase de conflit de la confrontation mondiale
C'est exactement ainsi que nous comprenons tout cela et
nous répondrons en conséquence
réagir
[musique]